hey 42 here let's take a look at some of
the wackiest weirdest animals that roam
the earth the grim paw feeis otherwise
known as the Dumbo octopus because of
its ear like fins is one of the weirdest
inhabitants of the deepest darkest
depths of the ocean they are found in
oceans all over the world but are very
rarely seen because they live at the
bottom of the sick
unlike most species of octopi that live
in shallow waters the Dumbo octopus
swallows its prey whole for that reason
the size of its prey never exceeds two
millimeters a little less pretty is the
eye eye this peculiar looking gleamer
isn't winning any awards for good looks
found only in the north eastern parts of
madagascar it is categorized for it's
scary appearance and the people of
Madagascar believed that seeing an
aye-aye
predicts death if you think that's weird
the hooded seal has an inflatable
bladder in its head it can inflate a
large red sack from its nostrils to
weave a ward off predators or to impress
females if you don't want to sleep
tonight then say hello to the promo cha
fear
sulcus a squid with actual human-like
teeth we only know about this rare
species because of a single specimen
caught by a German research vessel in
the southern Atlantic Ocean at a depth
of over 2,000 meters the prize for the
most bored animal goes to the Cape rain
frog a species of frog endemic to South
Africa it is essentially a rock with
arms which can't be much fun the
unfortunate looking naked mole-rat is
found in East Africa it has a highly
attuned and unusual set of physical
traits that enable it to survive in an
otherwise harsh
underground environment for example
they have no pain transmitters in their
skin whatsoever
and as a result feel absolutely no pain
when they are exposed to acid the dugong
is a large marine mammal related to the
manatee and elephant they are basically
the vacuum cleaners of the sea floor
feeding on underwater grasses with their
sensitive snouts
some believe dugongs were the
inspiration for the ancient sea firming
tales of mermaids and sirens the superb
bird-of-paradise is found in New Guinea
the species is known for its unique
courtship display the species has an
unusually low population of females so
competition amongst the males is fierce
this has led to the evolution of one of
the most bizarre occurrences in all of
the natural world in order to find a
mate first a male clears the dance floor
by meticulously scrubbing the floor
using a leaf until its movend clear the
male end attracts a female with a loud
call and next comes the dance it falls
its feathers into a large fan shape
forming an eerie blue face and dances in
a circle around the female even despite
this spectacular display the average
female rejects around 20 potential
suitors before consenting to mate
probably the ugliest thing in the entire
Animal Kingdom is the blobfish seriously
it actually was voted the world's
ugliest animal it inhabits the deep
waters around the coast of Australia
Tasmania and New Zealand its gelatinous
massive skin helps it maintain buoyancy
at 1,200 metres below sea level where
the pressure is several dozen times
higher than the surface of the ocean it
feeds off tiny floating matter and
generally just makes of a fish feel
depressed the Galapagos Islands is home
to a bat with lips no
is the red-lipped batfish these peculiar
looking fish aren't very good swimmers
and used their highly adapted pectoral
fins to walk on the ocean floor the
goblin shark is a deep sea monster
straight out of nightmares it is
extremely rare and has been called a
living fossil because it is the only
living representative of the Mitsu
Karina de family a lineage some 125
million years old specimens are very
rarely seen alive by humans because it
lives it depths greater than a thousand
meters beneath the ocean's surface the
Glaucus atlanticus or more commonly
known as a blue sea slug seems like it
could easily be an alien from another
planet you can find these otherworldly
creatures floating on the surface of
warm waters in the ocean it has a gas
filled stomach to help it float and
finally we have Scott o Plains commonly
known as sea pigs because of their plump
piggish appearance sea pigs live on the
ocean floor at depths of over a thousand
meters specifically on the abyssal plain
in the Atlantic Pacific and Indian
Oceans they obtain food by scuttling
along the ocean floor and extracting
organic matter from the deep sea mud
thanks to the view subscribe for more 42
Oh